こんにちははじめ社長です夏ぐらいから髪の毛を金髪にし
[音楽]
いやそういうことじゃないですよずっと様が金髪で生活していったんですがもうもう
髪の毛ば限界がきて髪の毛が限界だったんですよ
頭皮はいたにカフェや出さバサリアイブリッジ7回の影響により
しこのまあ気を取り切りたいそんな満期を乗り切りたいと思ってるんですけども限界
だったんで冷めてしまいました
こちら
ありがとうございます整えるだねだいぶいい感じだと思うんですよ結構こんにちは構成
したはじめ雪ようです
はいということで金髪終了いたしました
黒髪に戻しましたくる神って言っても何かうっすら茶色なんですよちょっとだけにいい
感じの茶色にしてください
いってこんな感じになったんですけどもまぁいかがでしょうかいやもうねぇ頻発目先に
行ってたんですけどもう本当に限界でした山染めたての頃はカッコイイですよなんか
全部金で凍っ思ってるんですけど雨のビルが早いんでだんだんだんだんその
プリンになっちゃって黒いのがピュッて出てきてそれが広がって広がっていっ買い直し
ましたとでまた次もといるまで広がって儲け治しますと痛いデー
痛いんだよとっても頭皮に直接んだから力役をぶつけるわけですからね
もうそんなの繰り返してるともうさすがに頭皮が持たんだと本当にハゲるしまうだと
思ってあの僕はこれで
金髪生活を終了し縁黒神として再びもう一度このように手を出すことに成功いたしまし
た
山尾ねあのねほんと金髪はかっこいいんですけどなんか期間限定とかに絞ったほうが
いいですって言う
すすめ時は皆にマジで金髪はね維持が大変ですってこれだったら伸びてきてもいつも
同じどうでしょ
最高じゃあカメラ必要がないんですよ傷みすぎてた前髪がでうにょねっ
うん効果こうだったと効果こうだったのでヘアピンとかで止めてなんですけども結局も
バッサバサ先でどうしてもなくて自分にバサって切った瞬間あ結果は前髪が無くなって
しまいました今ちょっとこういうチェックガッツリわけてる髪型になっちゃってるん
ですけどなんかで若返った気がしなくてはか言って馬鹿が入ったら後ろも短い
もう全体的に短く用意させていただきました
自分で言うのもなんですけどもまぁ確実に金髪の時よりかを爽やかになったのかなと
思っておりますとなんかこうでいろんな意義をいただくんですよ金髪の方がいいって
いう方もいらっしゃいますし
茶髪がいい黒髪がいいいろんな意見があったんですけどなぜ金髪のちょっと一杯黒と茶
の間みたいなちょっとだけ茶色みたいな色にさせていただきました
回ったほど前髪が伸びるの街みたいなところがあるんですけどさせずに秋までね秋まで
原発そっとで摩れに応援ってなると思うんですけど
さすがに秋まで金髪外上ってなると思うんでまあしばらく黒紙で行かせて頂きたいと
思っております
ちょっと世間の反応を見ていきましょう go 金髪の時に間違いなくかっこいいって
言われる回数が増えてるんですよ
男に入っ forever
barbie 黒髪どうですかジューシーな感想すっ
えっやっぱのシンプルにやってますよはいカッコイイ一
金閣ローがだったら
だからなぁ
かっこいいはカッコいいけどどっちも一じゃねぇ
さわやか感がありますよねません
だーラインナビとかもうこれで開けちゃってもいいですよ楽だなぁこれでいる乙とかの
日も気にせなくっていってこと進まずハッピー
はいというわけで髪の毛を黒くしたというお話でした絶対理由が入ってると思うんだ
金だけは持ったりしてないんでなんかすごいスラッとしてるって言われてちょっと
はじめ
嬉しいのです本当にみんなでどんな髪色がいいか取得把握したいんでよかったら
コメント欄で何色が良い抱えていただけるとありがたいでございますもう内容時代で僕
もう行け神変えようと思ってるんで
やっ乗りで1張った米正面さん僕はこれじゃあピュアな買いたくないんだゾンビの店が
黒でいいってプロ d 黒で行って来た名将第3泳者そうあのいろいろそれじゃんっ
me
バッハ